i'm here with the beautiful and talented
zoe de chanel whose new nickname is rad
angel
and we are here for craft week on our
show
and you love to craft zoey yeah
i do i love crafting it's like one of my
favorite things ever
and we've teamed up with cricut to make
something really special tell us
everything about it
i'm so excited to show you what we can
do with this it's
truly mind-blowing i am so excited to
actually learn from you and now i'll
always associate you with this majestic
machine
so look how small this is the cricut joy
and it is tiny
it's really light and you can basically
make
you know any kind of like a decal or an
iron-on depending upon the material you
can
totally customize almost
anything i can't actually think of a
thing you can't customize with the
cricut
um i thought we could make a card today
in honor of world kindness day
and you just like open it up it's just
kind of set you just have to hook it up
to your bluetooth on your phone
do you have your phone set up i do
so you have this little thing here this
is the yeah that's the card
the qriket joy card mat you're just
going to take a card like this
regular card and you're just going to
like hug the mat with it
and i put it inside right
yep exactly inside to protect the other
side since it's going to be cutting it
um so then you're going to take out your
phone or your ipad
and i'm doing this card that says
sending a smile and i'm going to press
start making and i'm going to choose my
card size
say next and put next
make it make it it's connecting
my card says something really crazy are
you ready
zoe it says yes thank you
[Applause]
well you know what you got to send thank
you notes right you absolutely do
so you're gonna just load your card in
okay
and i'm gonna do mine i'm just gonna say
go
it's preparing now just press um go
or make it so this is where
i just like to just watch it do its
thing it's really fun
are you watching oh yeah oh yeah it's
cutting so cool
it's so amazing it's a smart cutting
machine
that cuts shapes i could never cut by
hand and you can make
so many things so your card's done i
just press unload
unload okay i got it unload let you take
it out yeah so grab it
should be loose now okay so here i have
it
okay i'm so excited okay take the corner
and you can just peel it off it should
it should peel off pretty easily
so you can pick your background color do
you have some little there's
there are these little like cards that
come the cards come with contrasting
colors oh i
sure do pick whatever your favorite is
and you just basically so mine says
sending a smile
and i put this nice like teal kind of
color in
and it's so easy i've already made a
card i could just like do all my
christmas cards right now
i wanna that's another thing i finally
did like my first official
look at that zoe it's so christmassy
it's
bold and so beautiful isn't that so cute
so i have like a bunch of cards actually
to show you
um like this one this cute
llama one wait i have the llama
so i want i sent you some gifts of stuff
i made with the cricket
wait you did not really make this yeah
send it over to you well first of all it
you look like ingrid bergman in
casablanca
right now this is the most beautiful hat
by the way
thank you it's like i know fedora's this
is a beautiful fedora
oh my gosh look you do like your wine
like the bag it came
in oh my gosh yeah so you can do like
we got a custom bag you know you got
custom everything you can customize your
your ornaments zoey
yeah and there's your drew ornament
thanks to you zoey i now have like a new
memory
for oh my god i'm so happy
it's your first year doing your show of
many
and now you'll have your ornament so you
can remember
that 2020 wasn't just the year of a lot
of weird stuff
it was also the first year that your
wonderful show is on
zoey and i'm gonna be so happy to be
here with you
the she and him christmas album while i
decorate
the tree with my girl i would love that
well i listen to it every year facetime
me and
i'll help you if you want to do any yeah
any qriket crafts or i'll sing to you
whatever you want
zoey thank you and you too
can get to crafting and make kindness
and international kindness day sounds
like
my new favorite day of the year and you
can learn more at our website
thedrewberrymoreshow.com
zoey you're right this is a new memory
now for
2020 that i will cherish always
thank you thank you
[Music]
you